all right um
all right today
i'm going to host myself for the ddps
seminar um i would like to introduce
many many exciting data driven
simulation capabilities
we have developed in the past several
years here at lawrence livermore
national lab
i know you all are interested in
data-driven physical simulation so i'm
sure you will enjoy the talk today my
name is yong soo and
i was fortunate enough to work with
awesome reduced automobile teams here at
lawrence livermore dylan kevin and tony
and also both internal and external
collaborators of course all the results
i'm going to present today were not
possible without these awesome people
all right now let's start by arguing
about physical simulations first
there is
no doubt that physical simulations are
so essential for the advanced in science
and technology these days
well then how did we get the physics
physical simulation capability that we
are heavily relying on
i would argue that data
already played an important role just to
illustrate if you look at how we have
advanced
the orbital model of the solar system in
history
it starts with
copernican model it's correctly
postulated that planets orbit sun right
by
uh the telescopic observations of the
phase of venus
then kepler interpreted the more
observational data
of planetary motions by
tycho brahe
to develop kepler's three loads of
orbital motions
then newton further developed loads of
mechanics gravity
and calculus of course which is further
which is further advanced to
differential equations
and many physics laws
were written in terms of differential
equations such as navier stokes
street integers wave equations and many
other equations of motions
then computer came along greatly
improving the computing powers as well
as the numerical methods of solving
these differential equations thanks to
hilbert current and many other pioneers
right
this is how we have now physical
simulation capability that is advancing
science and technology
for example
you are looking at a beautiful
simulation model by smooth particle
hydrodynamics or shaped charge
penetration the simulation is well
matched with experiment and this kind of
simulations can be run routinely for
various applications
however it has limitation though
that is it can be very expensive for
example one fold simulation of this
particular shaped charge simulation
takes 7.4 days
this is unfortunate in multicure
applications such as design optimization
and uncertainty quantification
therefore we need a reduced auto models
that accurately accelerate these
expensive physical simulations here
again data plays a key role
of building on efficient reduced
automotives
a reduced stone model
can be built by
first considering a parameter space the
parameter space can be initial condition
boundary condition or material
properties of shape charged simulation
for example
then you collect simulation data by
solving full auto model with high
performance computing machines if you
have
or several sample points in your
parameter space
then you apply machine learning
techniques to build a video
various machine learning techniques are
available as listed here so various
reduced modeling types are possible but
depending on
how much you incorporate physics loads
in the reduced model
it can be intrusive or non-interesting i
will go over some advantages and
disadvantages of intrusive and
unintuitive methods in the next slide
but once
the reduction model is built you can
accelerate simulations and predict the
solution at various security points here
and there and many
other points
which you have not seen in the training
phases
and accurately at the same time so this
is obvious
obvious that reduced model is useful for
fast predictable calculations for
example in multi-carry applications
these reduced total models can be
categorized by its level of
intrusiveness
for example black box approach denoted
as bb here is the least intrusive method
requiring only data
then we can think of more intrusive
methods which is the linear subspace
reduced total model so called
ls form where the state fields are
represented by a compact linear subspace
an even more intrusive method that is
non-linear manifold with the stool model
so called an m long where the state
fields are represented by a compact
non-linear manifold
can be thought of
but roughly speaking more intrusiveness
means more accuracy so the intrusive
reduced models are more accurate than
black box approach if the same amount of
data are used
on the other hand more intuitiveness
means less speed up so the black box
method is faster than the intrusive
methods in general
also the physics constraints reduced to
model intrusive release models are more
robust in extrapolation than the black
box reduced models which will become
handy in multi-current applications such
as pd constraint optimization that will
that will become clear in the later of
later part of the
talk okay let me
try to introduce three different black
box reduced stereo models the first
black box approach is the linear
multi-step neural network this method
uses the linear subspace reduce
reduction approach so-called proposed
decomposition through svd singular value
decomposition
to let's look to illustrate that let's
say we have a airfoil flow data denoted
as w here
we use singular value decomposition to
obtain a reduced basis for the solution
variable
and then project
the original airfoil flow data w onto
the subspace band by the reduced basis
and obtain the reduced data a
then
the linear multi-step neural network is
trained
using the reduced data a and associated
parameter mu
in order to propagate in time in the
reduced latent space
then the full state is restored by the
reduced basis fee
as you can see we only use the data
throughout the whole process right so
this is black box reduced to all the
models
by the way this type of video model is
called latent space learning approach
it's taking latent space learning
approach the latent space learning
approach it has a two main ingredients
the first one is the compression
and the second one is the identification
for example this particular
example of particular method of linear
multistep neural network used the linear
compression
as a other identifications
and
the linear multi-step neural network for
no no the linear compression for for the
compression and the linear multi-step
neural network for the identification
all right we have applied this linear
multi-step neural network based
black box approach for a steady
flow around the airflow simulations
here we change the bach number to
generate the simulation data and then
compress them using the singular value
decomposition and train the linear
multistep neural network as i described
in three previous slides as you can see
that the predictive solution by this
surrogate model and the photo model are
identical in eyeball gnome
while the solar game model takes only
2.55 seconds while the full load model
takes 314 seconds giving us a speed up
of greater than 100 times
quantitatively the relative error
between those two solutions is less than
one percent uh everywhere pretty good
right
another way of generating generating the
reduced space or latent space is to use
auto encoder let's say we have porous
media flow data
encoder compresses the original data to
a latent space
then the decoder decompresses the latent
space data back to the full states the
encoder and decoder are some sort of
neural networks they have to be trained
are we trained by minimizing the
difference between the original data w
and the approximate data w tilde
then for the prediction
of the new parameter value mu star
various interpolation techniques can be
used such as radio basis function or
artificial neural neural network or some
other your favorite interpolation
techniques
this nonlinear compression technique is
compared with the proportional
decomposition the linear
the compression technique for the porous
media flow simulations and we found that
for the problems with kolmogorov with
decaying slowly meaning that
the objection dominated or the transport
dominated simulations
auto encoder approach which is the
non-linear compression technique
outperforms the pod method which is the
linear compression technique in terms of
accuracy
this fact will be handy when we talk
about the non-linear manifold-reduced
models so uh keep that in mind
similar non-linear compression approach
is used in deep fluids where the auto
encoder is used for compression and
decoder
decompression of the solution uh so the
original solution data w
the only difference here is that the
latent space dynamics are being learned
by the latent uh space integration
integrator after the autoencoders
auto encoder is trained
and after the auto encoder is trained um
after that the the latent space
integrator is
is trained
that integration will be very fast
because it's on under the the reduced
space
then with the predicted latent space
solutions from the latent space we
restore or reconstruct the full states
by applying the trained decoder
uh alex asked what a better picture of
the computational cost shouldn't be the
time spent to create high fidelity
results via phones be vectored in also
how general is a learned model
how
what's the trade-off between training
set size and the generality of the
learned predictor thank you all right
thank you for uh for the question alex
um yes i mean um well yeah to be fair um
it's um it has to be factored in but the
um the reduced model or the surrogate
models the the uses of those models in
in general is in in the multi carry
applications uh so for example
um
we there is a offline phase and online
phase offline phase um we train the
reduced uh with collect simulation data
and
um and um
and then
um
we collect the simulation data and uh
folders for some training points and um
the goal in the multi-carry applications
if we try to accelerate uh given a
surrogate more model or reduced model um
and accurately predict the solutions in
in online phase so
a lot of times um
if it is reasonable the the train the
training offline phase is is reasonable
it is plausible then we are
um willing to the you know to sacrifice
those expensive uh offline base however
as as i'm going to talk about later if
you have high dimensional parameter
space then you need to sample
exponentially many uh the sampling
points there it means exponentially many
of the photomodel simulations
in that case there it's impossible to uh
to even conduct the offline phase in
training phase so
that's the problem but that issue i'm
going to
touch upon later on
okay
yeah um i think that answered the
question but if not we can discuss more
in q and a sessions
all right
we have applied this black box approach
uh the the deep deep fluids to burgers
equations where the simulation is very
obviously dominated and the sharp front
is formed and moving
as you can see from the movie
the full auto model and the d fluid
solutions are very similar in eyeball
gnome while the deep fluid gives a speed
up of
greater than 100 using the latent space
dimension of only five
however uh the quantitatively the deep
fluid gives the maximum relative error
of 38.6
this might be good enough for animations
or digital graphics but it is a bit too
large
for scientific applications so for a
better accuracy we need to incorporate
the existing first principle or the
equation of state in our model
one way of doing this is to use reduced
model technique here i'm going to
introduce very traditional
projection-based reduction model
approach to do that we will start with
this governing equation represented by
this ordinary differential equation here
w is a state variable f is your
non-linear times and the t is the time
variable and mu is your parameter let's
imagine
okay and we first approximate the
solution as a linear combination of
reduced basis fee
whose dimension is a lot smaller than
the photomodel dimension big answer of s
here the key word is linear subspace
then you plug the solution
representation into the governing
equations
you will end up with an over determined
system right where you have more
equations than unknowns
so to close the system you apply some
kind of projections here i have applied
the galactic project projection that
gives a reduced system of ordinary
differential equations here
then you can apply your favorite time
integrator to this reduce the system for
example i have applied the black um the
backward euler time time integrator
just for the demonstration purpose
this gives us the fully discretized
reduced nonlinear system of equations
you have to solve in every time step
right by the way uh you have to treat
these non-linear terms
carefully otherwise this reduced model
will be slower than the photo model so
what's the point of introducing all
these uh uh complicated techniques um at
the end of the day it is slower than the
fluid model so
we
in order to achieve the efficiency we
have to apply the hyper reduction to
treat these non-linear terms correctly
the most famous hyper reduction
technique is deim
arguably
which stands for discrete uh empirical
interpolation methods the dim
introduces the nonlinear basis piece of
f and then express the nonlinear terms
as a linear combination of the nonlinear
basis vectors as we did for the solution
basis right
then it introduces a sampling matrix v
which selects an important subset of the
nonlinear terms
so after the action of z on the
non-linear term f only the subset of the
f will be evaluated
now the sampling indices of the matrix z
can be obtained through the various
algorithms which i'm not going to go
into details but the dim and qdins are
the variance and popular ones
then the generalized coordinates for the
non-linear term f of hats can be
obtained by solving the interpolation
problem then you plug this expression
into the reduced system of equations
wherever the nonlinear term shows up
then you will end up with this crazy
looking equations but if you look at
them close enough most of the terms can
be precomputed and
this nonlinear terms can be efficiently
computed thanks to the sampling matrix z
in front of the nominal term f
this is how we
this is how we achieve the efficiency
through the reduced model and hyper
reduction
there are many variants of dim
for example gnat and stig net and sns
but the main machinery of the hyper
reduction follows this paradigm that i
have just introduced here
all right this
traditional uh the linear subspace
reduced to the model can be used uh to
accurately accelerate various physical
simulations achieving a speed up of 10
to 1000 with a relative error less than
one percent or five percent for example
but anders uh asked is oil a backward
really your favorite method it is very
dissipative with
hamper's long-term accuracy yeah good
point anders
the time integrator has to be chosen uh
for
uh for for your applications and for
your government equation so far yeah so
um it is my favorite method
but
for the wave equations for example the
applications you are mainly dealing with
probably the backward euler integration
is not the good one okay
can you elaborate more on zero thank you
brenda for the equations is it
stochastic no it's not stochastic so so
the z matrix we actually we do not form
the z matrix it's it's a if you look at
the structure of the g matrix it's it's
basically the selected the column of the
identity matrix which corresponds the
selected one is corresponding to the
sampled sampled
sampled elements in the nonlinear terms
and
we obtained that using various
algorithms like dim or qdim basically um
the physics inform the greedy
not physics informed
some greedy algorithm
is applied to select those sampling
matrices
but it is not stochastic and it's yeah
it's um yeah i can go into detail
later with you brenda
okay
all right um okay as i said this linear
subspace reduced model has been
successfully applied to for example
tough simulations such as lagrangian
hydrodynamics
which you're seeing here
but not only the with the linear
subspace resistance model we have to add
the time windowing approach in order to
overcome this uh advection-dominated
phenomena from the lagrange
hydrodynamics
and with that um
we were able to obtain a speed up of
great speed up uh like from 14.6
um and 22.8 and 31.2 and 87.8 uh for all
these lagrangian hydrodynamic
simulations and with great accuracy if
you if you compare the the solutions
with the follow the model for example
then we get the relative error less than
one percent not not even the less than
one percent like less than zero point
one percent which implies that if you
compare the digital model solution with
the full the model solution it's not
distinguishable
at all
all right
one great thing about this
this reduced auto models projection
based reduced model is that its speed up
will increase as we apply it to larger
scale problem
just to see that effect we have
refined the rayleigh taylor instability
problems and observe the speed up
as you can see from the graph a higher
speed up is achieved as the size of the
problem increases
okay john
ragusa asked are the results shown
reproductive case or are the simulation
parametric so
the one i showed
here in this slide is the reproductive
case
however
the one i'm going to show right now is
the predictive case so let me explain
what this is
okay
another great things about this
reduction model is its robustness
with extrapolation unlike the black box
approach uh since the reduced model
directly incorporates the governing
equations for the underlying physics
remember we have
plugged the reduced representation into
the governing equations right so we are
using the the physics um
in in reduced number
so because of that even though it is
used to predict the solution for the
parameter points away from the training
data it can still give a reasonable
accuracy for example this graph shows
the relative adders of the local reduced
model that is trained at the blast
energy
0.25 right at this point of course at
that point is the most accurate because
the reduced model is trained there
and as we expected
if
if we try to predict the solution
for other initial blast energy for
example in 38.4.5
the accuracy is deteriorating
it is expected but however
not much though as you can see from
around 0.4 to 0.4 these regions
this local register model is still can
observe the relative error less than one
percent
um you know even the worst error uh
being less than one percent so it means
that
you know the reduced auto model the
projection reducing model physics
constrained with the store model is more
robust than the purely data driven
method and purely data-driven methods
cannot achieve this kind of
extrapolation accuracy because they do
not incorporate the physics law this is
kind of the real real benefit of using
the physics of physics constraint model
all right this has a great implications
for example in gradient based
optimization let's say you do not have
sensitivity implementation as you may
know the implementation of the
sensitivity can be quite complicated in
this case you can approximate the
gradient using the finite difference as
i have written here
in the finite difference evaluations you
can evaluate this function evaluations
the perturbed function evaluation using
the using the extrapolation capability
of the local reduced model right using
that you can compute this quantity
pretty accurately and pretty fast and
and so that you can
compute the finite difference uh schemes
uh using the local reduced models pretty
well and you can use the gradient-based
optimization server for example
all right another implication is that
you can easily add more local reduced
models to cover the broader parameter
domain right each local reduce model has
a trustworthine for this one from 0.1 to
4 in order to broaden the parameter
space and you can build another local
reduce model around 6.4.6
so that overall the relative error is
less than less than one percent or some
target accuracy you would like to
achieve but here there is the questions
you have to ask
how do we are going to
obtain those sampling points the
location of where the local views water
has to be built right that can be
achieved by these physics constraints
uh physics informed
the the greedy algorithms
somehow this one is not in
all right great
all right so the greedy algorithm tries
to find the self-optimal if not optimal
set of local reduced models whose
overall accuracy is less than
some desirable accuracy level say for
example three percent
as a demonstration we set our parameter
space to be plus energy changing from
0.075 to 1.25
just to show how different how different
dynamics are are for those endpoints
like 0.075 and 1.25 the movie on the
on the right
shows the seed of
movie on the left here
it shows the the seed of blast dynamics
with the initial blast energy of 0.075
and the one on the right shows the
dynamics with the initial blast energy
of 1.25 for example this
this dynamics does not the shock wave is
formed but it does not hit the boundary
while the this dynamics shows the shock
wave is propagating and
hit the boundary and reflect it and it's
it's interact with the incoming waves
and etc complicated right
all right so
to illustrate the greedy algorithm
the greedy algorithm starts by setting a
desirable
accuracy level as i said let's say three
percent relative error everywhere
and then
it builds a first local register model
so you gotta start with some videos
model so we build a local reduced model
for example in the middle but it's it
was my choice you could build a reduced
model in the end point right for example
and then compute error indicator of
which has some sort of the physics in it
and we usually use the residual based
error indicator which we did for this
particular problem
um
and we compute the error indicator over
the whole uh you know the parameter
space and then find where the maximum
error maximum error indicator occurs
which is indicated by this red
points
then
we build a second local reduce model
there and now we have to update
the error indicators around the second
local reduce model because they will be
small due to the second local resistance
model right
then find the next maximum error
indicator which is depicted at this as
this red point here and you repeat uh uh
you build the release model the third
reduced model there um
you repeat this process as you can see
uh until
uh the overall the error of the accuracy
level is is
higher than the the target accuracy
level
all right here is an actual greedy
algorithm result we plot a graph of
relative error with respect to the
initial blast energy from 0.075 to 1.25
as i said
and then the target relative error is a
relative error of the three percent uh
that's what we are trying to achieve
and using the greedy algorithm i that i
just described
it spits out the 15 local reduced models
depicted as this blue dots here
and as you can see if you compute the
relative error everywhere
as you can see the the older relative
error is less than three percent
which is pretty good
and because this grid algorithm
incorporates the error indicator that is
physics informed usually we use the
residual based error indicator it picks
these points of optimally if not
optimally if you use for example latin
hypercube sampling or tensor product
sampling
or any random or statistical sampling
you would not be able to achieve this
minimal number of points for the same
level of accuracy so this is the power
of again the physics-informed degree
sampling the procedure
all right
we have explained this detailed
description of these linear
subspace-reduced models in this paper
which we expect to be accepted pretty
soon in cmame
and the following two softwares are
available so that you yourself can
generate these results
also as a matter of fact we have
recently launched the webpage of the
librarian the one of the the library the
software for the video student models
where you can find many useful tools
regarding physics constraints reduced
models for various physical simulations
additionally several youtube videos are
about the reduced models are available
so take advantage of it all right here
are some more detailed snippets of the
libram the librarian is a library for
registered models for um as i said it
has several features first librarian can
do efficient proper orthonormal
decomposition using various singular
value decomposition techniques such as
static svd incremental svd randomized
svd and space time svd especially this
incremental svd which can be also
combined with the spacetime svd is very
attractive if you deal with a large
scale simulation data
and the librarian also has a dynamic
mode decomposition capability and if you
click example tabs in the webpage for
example then you will be able to find
several examples four feet the dynamic
mode decomposition decomposition is
applied such as
advection
advection problem and the euler
equations
and the heat conductions
and the non-linear elasticities as and
so on
and the protection-based resistance
model examples can be found in libron
webpage also
such as poisson problem
nonlinear diffusion problem and several
lagrangian hydrodynamics problems which
i have presented in previous slides
finally the librom has greedy algorithm
capability that i have introduced in
previous slides
so so please take advantage of it and at
the same time the older source codes are
provided so you can download the
librarian and generate these results
yourself
so please play with it and get your
hands dirty um
however if you are new to data driven
physical simulations i would recommend
to first look into pleasant examples
which has also the youtube tutorial
about it
three of them
and we plan to add more examples and uh
capabilities so please stay tuned and
please take advantage of it and keep
saying it
and if you are reduced by the way if you
are reduced all the model developers
then we welcome your contributions
since libram is an open source code
which is available in github
let's work together to add cool videos
to the models capabilities right okay
be
with us
all right great
all right
unfortunately though the linear subspace
released studio models have a great
limitations that is it cannot accurately
represent a long-time
objection-dominated solution with a
small basis size without any special
treatments let's look at the 2d burgers
problem that you have seen in previous
slides the solution is very advanced and
dominated as you can see from the movies
the ls from linear surface form
shows fictitious oscillation in front of
the shark wave if if the reduced
space dimension of 5 is used
resulting in in a relative error around
34 which is not good enough for many
scientific applications
the limitation of this linear surface
reduction model
if you think about it comes from the
fact that the solution is represented by
a linear combination of a fixed reduced
basis
this issue needs to be addressed i mean
the time windowing approach i have shown
for the lagrange and hydrodynamics
that's one of them
then that's one way but as a matter of
fact many researchers came up with a
different potential solutions for this
issue for example the the shifted pod by
rolly and race
and the registration based model by
tommaso tadai in india and raiden the
transformed based reduced models and
reduced the deep network by tons of lee
an implicit feature tracking based
method by metcher and the time windowing
resistor models our own the lagrange and
hydrodynamics by dylan copeland
and these methods are indeed promising
and needs more research effort but for
the best of my knowledge these four
methods are still under development to
be extended to fully 3d problems
and the time windowing reduction model
requires many many windows to handle a
long time of vex and dominated problems
therefore
for now let's focus on the non-linear
manifold reduced model which is first
introduced by gucci and kevin karberg in
2020 where the linear subspace solution
representation is replaced by the
nonlinear manifold solution
representation
although they were able to obtain a
great accuracy with a small size of
latent space which was really good
but their method was slower than the
full load of the model because the
non-linear manifold business model is
adding more non-linearity to the
original government equations and the
jacobian computation of the neural
network becomes a bottleneck in during
the fast computation
so today
now i'm going to present a version of
nonlinear manifold resistant model that
is now a lot faster than the photo model
simulation using a hyper reduction and a
special structure of the neural network
all right to formally explain the
non-linear manifold reduce model here is
the governing equation you have seen
before where w is your solution variable
and solution variable and the f region
of linear terms and mu is your the
parameter parameter values okay and
first we approximate the solution with a
nonlinear manifold which is represented
by the non-linear function g here
that maps a small latent space dimension
to full order model dimension
the nonlinear map is obtained
through the autoencoder training with
the solution data from the corresponding
fluid model simulations
note that this decoder
is mapping the latent space to the full
order states so it is perfect for our
non-linear map function g
so we use the decoder as the nonlinear
map function
then
we plug this nonlinear manifold solution
representation into the governing
equation and obtain the over determined
system where you have
more equations than unknowns here
you must be careful with the non-linear
terms as i emphasized before we need to
sample and compute only a subset of the
nonlinear terms through hyper reductions
okay
all right so when you do the hyper
reduction though the structure of the
neural network matters for the
efficiency of the nonlinear manifold to
reduce total model let's first look at
the neural network with two heat
one hidden the two hidden layers as a
decoder let's say that the orange disk
here in the outputs and nodes are the
selected ones by the sampling matrix z
in the hyper reduction remember
and you will notice quickly that many
hidden nodes many hidden nodes are
connected
to this selected output nodes
and as you go deeper and deeper in the
hidden layers the number of connected
hidden nodes are increasing very fast
this actually degenerates the efficiency
of the non-linear manipulators model
because the jacobian computation of this
neural net is very expensive
on the other hand if you use a shallow
neural network there is one hidden layer
then you can
easily see that the last number of
hidden nodes are connected to the
sampled outputs
which brings us an ultimate efficiency
in the nonlinear manifold reduced model
after we extract the soft subnet of
children's nose which is depicted as
this orange orange notes and if as you
can imagine if you specify the structure
even further then you will get even
better efficiency right because the size
of the selfnet will be very small and
the computation of the jacobian of the
subnet will be very efficient
efficient all right here we compare the
performance of all the reduced auto
models that i have
introduced in this presentation
including the non-linear manipulation
model and i'm wrong linear subspace
reduced to model and
and the black box approach deep fluid as
you can see from the movies and then rom
and flute model are almost identical in
eyeball norm
and quantitatively and then rom achieves
less than one percent maximum relative
error furthermore
a speedup of 11 is achieved by the nmr
so it's pretty good
okay uh the switching gear a little bit
another potential way of overcoming the
issue caused by the artifacts and
dominated problem is to
use the space-time resistance model and
it achieves a very maximal
you know the reductions in reduced
models okay the space-time views model
tries to reduce not only the spatial
degrees of freedom but also the temporal
degrees of freedom it does that by
introducing both space and time reduced
bases they are combined through the
chronicle product to represent the whole
space and time solution space
then the coefficient corresponding to
the space-time basis vectors are the
only unknowns which maximally reduces
the total number of unknowns
then
the space-time solution representation
is plugged again back into the space
time the formulations
of the full of the model and form the
over-determining system
again that this over-determined system
needs to be closed by taking the normal
we do that by taking the norm of the
space-time residual and minimizing it
again here we have to careful with the
non-linear residual times in order to if
uh get the efficiency we need to apply
the hyper reduction and this g bar is
representing the the weighting matrix of
the sampling matrix
for the space-time residual times of
r bar
okay we have applied this space-time
resistant model to a large-scale
particle transport problem whose problem
size is around 10 billion in space and
time domain
and using space-time video studio models
we were able to reduce the 10 billion
degrees of freedom to only 10
and still gets the pretty much the same
physics response as shown in the movie
the full of the model took 17.4 seconds
with 256 6 cores which is not bad but
the space-time reduced model was able to
finish the simulation within
0.006 seconds
with only one core
that gives us a wall time speed up of
2700 and quantitatively the relative
error was less than one percent
throughout the time history if you use
the time thing if you use the basis
dimension of 10.
all right the last topic i would like to
share is the component-wise register
model lattice design algorithm this is
not particularly a method of handling
the odd friction dominator problem or
hyperbolic on the simulations but it is
a nice way of overcoming the issue of
distributed parameter space which is
very high dimensional remember the um
when i answer one of the one of the
questions from the audience before the
high dimensional uh the parameter space
is causing real problem because it
requires exponentially many the sampling
points
but
using
this component wise reduced model
we are able to
resolve that issue very
nicely so i would like to introduce that
method um right now briefly um as a last
topic
okay as an applications
and
of the component-wise business model we
looked at microstructure design or meta
material designs and
although it's not the only uh you know
the applications this was a process a
perfect application
okay so microstructure design and meta
material designs are great interest
these days because of the advance in 3d
printing right i don't think anyone is
going to argue about about that
and there are many microstructures found
in nature oyster shell bone honeycomb
and cactus lettuce etc blah blah blah
blah there are so many
and all these
are there because they can achieve the
maximum strength with light weight right
so many industries national labs and the
universities are trying to mimic these
attractive features of natal materials
by looking for
an optimal design
but we have some problem here to model
the lattice type structure it would be
the most accurate if we use the
monolithic finite element method with
very high resolution unfortunately this
is computationally very expensive
this again hinders a fast board
calculation
which is unfortunate in design
optimization context because many fold
calculations are needed to explore the
parameter space
to accelerate the lattice structure
design optimization process with good
accuracy
we have developed a component-wise
reduced model which was first pioneered
by professor patera's group at mit
and we have extended it to lattice
structure design process
let me explain the process of the
component-wise register models in the in
the in the design optimization contest
first of all we have to identify the
reference components here we have
identified the simple joint
and stroke components geometry as you
can see here right
then you introduce final element
discretization for each reference
component
then we build then we build
and then we build uh the reducing models
for each component that is joint rom and
strut run
and within uh the process of building
component reduced models we introduce
very important concept called ports
which is an interface that talks to
environments it connects with other
component rom
it can be used to impose boundary
conditions
and of course you can add more
components through an available port
right
and also it can be used to apply
external force you can even rotate the
components and attach to the system and
attach many mores as you as you reach
the form in order to form your desirable
system domain
then in design optimizations
we assign a density variable
to each component which varies from zero
to one usually we avoid zero to ensure
the well posedness of the problem
so we set our low bounds to be 0.01
usually
and the small
the density variable implies putting no
material there and density of 1
implies you put the material
there
we automatize this procedure by solving
design optimization problem and to find
an optimal lattice structure for example
to minimize the compliance of the system
or
or minimizing the mass with the stress
constraints
all right here is a numerical example
for lattice structure design using
component-wise reduction model here we
minimize compliance imposing a
constraint of the mass being at most 40
percent the downward pressure force is
applied on the top middle and dirichlet
boundary conditions are of imposed at
the bottom corners the full monolithic
final element solve involves 2.7 million
degrees of freedom while the seat of the
rom has only about you know 4 000
degrees of freedom we apply the
optimization so we're called
the method of moving asymptotes so
called the mma which is very popular in
solving the density based topology
optimization problem
and this movie hopefully it's explained
okay it does work this this movie shows
the optimization history from the
beginning
and to the the final optimal uh shape of
the lattice structure initially it
started with the uniform density
variables and evo it evolves into an
optimal design where the blue components
implies no material right
and then the red component you put the
material so it it does give you the
optimal shape of the lattice structure
all right let's look at the speed up and
the accuracy of the component-wise
reduced model for this particular
numerical examples the cw rom the
component-wise register model achieved a
660 time speed up with respect to the
monolithic finite element solved
and for accuracy uh we easily achieved a
relative error of less than one percent
but the nice thing about this
component-wise reduced to the model is
that the accuracy can be tuned by adding
more bases so we observe that the
exponential improvement of the accuracy
as we increase the basis size pretty
pretty nice
and this component-wise reduced
automobile lattice structure design can
be applied for stress constraint problem
also
where the mass is minimized with the
stress constraints this is considered to
be harder problem than minimizing the
compliance problem
here we introduced a four different
components
then we define a computational domain
which shape is l bracket
which is a typical stress constraint
a benchmark problem
then we assemble and fill the
computational domain with the four
component roms as you can see right here
and then
throughout the optimization process
delete unnecessary components to find
out the optimal l bracket lattice
structure here all the blue components
are eliminated throughout the
optimization process
and then
here is the zoomed in picture of the
components in the optimal design with
very detailed stress contour
plots which you cannot get
with other types of lattice structure
design methods such as homogenization or
beam based methods
finally
we can post process the design
to get rid of all the hanging nodes
hanging structure then we get this
smooth and nice lettuce
lettuce design for l bracket
okay
we have also solved the stress
constraint problem for 2d breach
lattice structure design with component
wise reduced to the models a paper about
stress constraint component wise reduced
model is coming soon so plea please stay
tuned
all right let me conclude the talk with
some summary i hope i have introduced
many interesting reduced order model
techniques
data driven and physics physics
constraints approaches
the examples i have shown you include
black box approach deep fluid on 2d
burgers equations
and the linear subspace reduction models
applied to various lagrange and
hydrodynamics including cedar blast and
rayleigh tail instability etc
however the linear subspace resistor
model was not able to achieve a good
accuracy for long-time
advection-dominated simulations with
small reduced space dimensions without
special treatments
such as the timing during approach
therefore we introduced a non-linear
manifold register model that finally
achieves a speed up with a great
accuracy for advection-dominated
simulations with small latent space
dimension
and then the space-time reduced auto
model that achieves a a 2 700 speed up
with a relative error less than 1
percent for particle transport problem
and the component wise visual studio
model for lattice structure design that
accurately accelerates the optimization
process considerably
finally i have introduced the webpage
for the librarian where you will find
many useful tools to build data driven
physical simulation models
all right if you
find
the things that i have presented today
useful for your applications please let
me know and let
let our registered model team know so
that we can help you out and develop
awesome data-driven physical simulations
techniques together
with that let me conclude my talk and
thank you for your attention and
any questions are welcome
by the way
there was
okay let me go back to the chat room and
i answered the john rogers the questions
shall
ask that i think sometimes it is super
expensive to generate a reduced model
for
the prediction of every grid point of
the computational domain
however if we focus on
some handful small size specific
quantities of interest or small domain
of computational domain then the time
spent on generating the training data
for building rom can be achievable
especially when it is not
computationally tractable for generating
even just
a few data points i think it might be a
good idea to relate the training to the
goal
we need to target and reduce
reduce
reduce the model complexity based on the
high fidelity model and the goal in mind
so the offline time that i think will
depend on the goal in the mind yes for
example yeah
so definitely very valid and good points
and actually the component-wise model is
kind of addressing that issue right we
are kind of uh
doing the training on this uh the small
component right and then
we assembled that reduced model just
like that we assembled the final
elements and instead of finite element
we we are
attaching the component rom together
right so
so that's
yes i mean the training cost can be very
um very much reduced in that way and
also in terms of the goal
there are of course the goal-oriented
register models
available in literature for example um
[Music]
um
masa masa or friend of mines from
uh from canada uh to toronto university
of toronto he he does a lot of works on
goal oriented videos to models um so and
not only masa and
many other uh the researchers in ridge
from the community they do uh build
goal oriented videos to models so yes
it's definitely a way to to investigate
okay the next question is by peter
and okay scaling of speed up with
problem size is this because the rom
doesn't grow as fast as the original
problem well because the wrong
implementation scales better
computationally than the original
simulation yes exactly right
as we increase the problem size uh
whether because of the
the complicatedness or because of the
um you know based on the convergence
study you know this is the the required
the refinements the resolutions you have
to maintain
um it's the the the speed up of the
reduced model all you know boils down to
how much it can compress the solution
space into the reduced reduced space and
the speed up um
small speed up is going to be achieved
as
as you can uh achieve more compressions
in your videos and video spaces so
so it's not so much about the um
it's it's not so much about the uh
about the size of the high fidelity
models uh it's about the the
compressibility uh where the uh the
speed up of the reduced model on and
also the accuracy of the resist model uh
and depends on so
so a lot of times um you know the the
parabolic
or
the equations has very small uh the
intrinsic uh
the spatial dimensions uh which can um
represent the whole the high fidelity
solutions with a small small
small basis size
that's exactly why the reduced model was
able to
obtain a higher the speed up as you
increase the increase the uh the problem
size as long as that uh the problem has
you know the small uh you know the
chromograph width right i mean the
chromograph width if as long as the
homogeneous width is uh decaying fast
then the videos model can
obtain the higher accuracy and high
accuracy and with a higher
better speed
okay next question is by brenda do we
use the non-linearity of f to inform the
dimensionality of
hat w
is there a systematic way to determine
the dimensionality
okay so
um
the dimensionality of the head w which
is the solution uh the generalized
coordinates the size of the solution uh
space field
it's not depend it's it is not um uh you
know determines it is not determined by
where is brandon's problem okay it is
not determined by uh the the
non-linearity of course nonlinearity is
going to affect the solution fields and
solution dynamics but mainly um is it's
the characteristic of the dynamic which
is determining the um determining the
the basis size of the videos relational
models or the size of the head w in in
your questions according to your
questions
so so um and actually when we determine
the the dimensionality of the non-linear
terms by the way
we do use the solution basis um in the
context of sns
sns method which i didn't go into
details but we can use the solution
basis or the modified
version of the solution basis
to
um infer
the
the basis size for the non-linear terms
at the f um
it's it's it's technically details uh
that tech is i have to go into the
technical details and so i you know
let's let's meet brenda and then uh
discuss water
all right john
your slice 22 let me go to slice 22
okay slice 22
here is 22.
okay what difference do you make between
pod and project
based rom
okay the pod is a method of
obtaining a reduced basis
the the projection-based resistance
model in within the projection-based
reduced model you use that reduced
spaces and plug that into the uh the
governing equations and then apply the
garlic and projection or list square
project this secure pattern of garlic in
projections and any any other
method of closing the the
over-determined system that's what i
mean by projection based reduce model so
so there's a distinction between those
two
uh yes means yes the the most the
reduced spaces can be can be obtained
from
um
not only from the pod modes but also
many other uh
many other uh ways um you know you can
get the the pod modes uh
you know balance truncation method is
one of them and yeah there are there are
many other ways of you know obtaining
the projection base through the the
radio spaces in the projects and
basically some other the pod is not the
only one right
okay carol lina
are
the connections assumed to have the same
material properties stiffness as the
struts or
are they different so i i think you are
talking about
on the lattice structure
um
the component-wise visual studio models
right yes i mean the the stiffness or
young's modulus or
or the the poisson's ratio we have used
the different uh different types of
i mean we have used the identical
material proposes for each component
however
those material properties can be
parameterized right
and
we can train the reduced model each
component resistor model by varying the
those material properties stiffness etc
then each component rom is going to be
able to handle those variations of the
material uh properties uh while
when you are using those component-wise
reduce model in the context of design
optimization so it is it is
very possible and it's it's actually
straightforward to do so
so if you are interested in more about
that
please let me know carolina
all right
jay
asked in cw rom optimization example how
is the sensitivity information computed
by numerical finite
by numerical finite difference or
analytical adjoin method
so
very good questions the compliance uh
the minimization problem uh it's it
worked out mathematically really nicely
so we only need a fold so for the
solutions and using that right inside
the external force and that
um
coincidentally match uh with the adjoin
method formulation so we don't need to
uh to solve separate enzo and so
the method uh at the joint problem to
compute the sensitivity
however for the stress constraint
problem
we do have to uh go over the adjoin
method because it has a different right
hand side because the quantity of
interest has been changed uh so um we do
we did uh the implemented the uh the
head joint method for cw rom and we did
not use the finite difference uh for for
the sensitivity computation okay peter
he asked what can wrong tell us about
original physics can you point back to
the
important unimportant physics
dominating the solutions
ignoring
correction x
in the original model will be
faster without sacrificing significant
accuracy
okay so
so you want to go back to the
slide where i talked about
the you know the advantage and this
advantage of using the physics
physics constraint or not so
um so so important
things about physics constraints is that
as i uh illustrated
a physics constraint data driven method
as i illustrated before it is more
robust in
in
extrapolations
right um so i have demonstrated that in
the
um with the with the acetyl blast uh the
problem using the local reduced model we
perturbed the parameter space so we were
able to still get the pretty good
accuracy however if you're if you are
not using the physics in your model then
you don't get that extrapolation
capability because
it only knows the data
it didn't incorporate the physics laws
and so when you extrapolate
the data method has no idea where to go
but the physics constraint the method
they know they are guided by the physics
law so so in that sense
the
physics constraints
the data-driven method is more
beneficial
also it it tends to require less
sampling data
than the data driven because it is not
only relying on the data but also it
relying on the physics physics company
equations uh
on the other hand the data or purely
data driven methods
only relying on the data so it tends to
use a lot more
uh a lot more uh a lot more data than
the physics constraint
methods all right i think i hope i have
answered your questions all right if not
please do not hesitate to contact uh
contact me okay next question is by
emmanuel
very nice walk i could expect it to be
difficult to reproduce a highly
non-linear system in a reduced
space it seems you are able to reproduce
the most important features
of the flow this is great i wonder if
you can make sense of what are the
important components and why for example
i would be interested to see the
performance of your your approach to
fluids that have lagrangian coherence
structure
this could be an interactive way to
detect lcs great yeah um
well emmanuel do you wanna uh do you
wanna collaborate on this uh we will be
happy to do so so
please um let's let's be on contact uh
let's let's let's communicate on that
all right carolina thank you
uh
thank you for your answer for the
sensitivity analysis in cw wrong
following of your answer i'm wondering
if the answering sensitivity is
performed in the level of reduced video
space as well or full order space yeah
of course in the reduced space and not
only the reduced space but component
reduces space so we walked out the
sensitivity
within the um oh well yes uh let me take
back yes and the sensitive joint method
has to be
on the assembled the system but
those assembled system is consists of
the reduced components right so the size
of the joint
system uh the equations
is smaller a lot smaller than the using
the monolithic finite element method so
that's why it is it is efficient
a lot more efficient than using the
monolithic monolithic binary element all
right so i i do think that i have um
i do think that i have answered all the
questions from q a uh from the chat room
uh if you have any
questions you can admit yourself and ask
ask directly
okay masa a nice talk a very broad range
of methods and application i enjoy it
very much okay thank you oh martha you
you just messed me internally okay thank
you thank you vasa all right um
if there's no questions
let me
let's end here thank you so much for
attending the tdp seminar it was you
know without without you guys support um
we cannot do this alone uh thank you so
much so please keep supporting us by
attending and and so on and also please
recommend any uh you know speakers you
would like to hear the presentation of
then we can do our best to invite those
speakers also all right
thank you so much
have a nice
rest of the day
and i will see you next time okay bye
bye everyone
let me stop recording